comment ça va tout mais parra espagnole
movistar à quatre ans et demi
ronnie est en voie de réaliser le rêve
de son père ja il devenir polyglotte et
pourquoi pas plancher
beaucoup de choses que j'ai réussi dans
ma vie grâce à laquelle seront luc
harousseau dans une tombe
moi j'aimerais mener le monde
le père de joannie têtu yonne a lui-même
a pris plusieurs langues dès son jeune
âge anglais français japonais dans leur
ai espagnols sont les cinq langues que
je maîtrise que j'ai quand je parle
couramment taïwanais d'origine
il a fréquenté une école américaine
avant d'arriver au québec à l'âge de 13
ans je passais des haricots
toutes les places parce que l'anglais ne
parlait pas beaucoup la famille de thé
dessous yoko son épouse japonaise et
leurs trois enfants l'aîné ronnie nique
à trois ans et le petit dernier à kiel à
trois mois
arrivé depuis peu au québec yoko est en
immersion française en 2015
ils sont arrivés ici cinq mois 1 parce
que j'ai pas fini mais c'est une
pandémie rester au japon
au japon des couples en union mixte
comme ci dessous et yuko on en compte
près de 400 milles au canada dès la
naissance
leurs enfants ont la possibilité
d'apprendre au moins deux langues à la
maison de langues ou plus c'est ce qui
est parlé par plus de six millions de
canadiens n'est pas d'accord
leur maison de brome ans est un
véritable laboratoire cinq langues à
table une vraie joute de ping pong le
japonais manga c'est simple c'est parce
que dans notre famille on a besoin de
ces l'angle anglais ça va de soi et puis
le français étant donné qu'on vit ici et
puis l'espagnol
nous on croit que c'est une langue qui
au vainqueur un futur côté économique la
motivation de le faire aussi jeune
aussitôt c'est par expérience moi je
sais que je les ai appris de cette
manière la saed d'apprendre une nouvelle
langue qu'on est très jeune presque ça
nous permet de perdre notre accent et
d'apprendre à prononcer très bien la
nouvelle en tout le monde s'en va dans
la direction où ce qu'il faut parler au
mans et deux sinon trois langues
peut-être qu'ils dirigent de chez lui
des études cliniques dans le domaine
pharmaceutique il est en contact
permanent avec la planète collectionne
des canards csq racines à préserver tous
les singles ans que je les reprends je
pense à couvre c'est pas 80% de la
population ça sur la planète dans la
famille de titres sous on a mis en place
une stratégie d'apprentissage pour
éviter la confusion chez les enfants une
personne une langue c'est la règle du 1
1 chacun
les mômes à ma fille un peu non avec mon
papa film anne marie et ce n'est pas
tout les grand parent et deux filles au
pair vivent en permanence avec la
famille andrea mexicaine apprend aux
enfants l'espagnol et caroline danoise
communique en anglais se porte très bien
les langues dans leur tête ils savent
exactement à qui parler at-elle ans ils
savent exactement c'est quoi le lan qui
leur ai parlé il ya des gens qui parlent
plusieurs langues ils ont tendance à
faire ce qu'on appelle du conte
switching ou du changement de code donc
de passer d'une langue à l'autre on voit
qu'ils ont aucune confusion
c'est plutôt une maîtrise très près
forte d'un contexte toyota et des piles
maîtriser le changement de code c'est la
base mais d'autres ingrédients sont
nécessaires à la recette du
multilinguisme
ça prend un lien affectif quand un
enfant est dans un contexte où il doit
communiquer avec une personne importante
ou significatives émotivement importante
dans sa vie c'est ce que ça fonctionne
mieux la communication vox y suivre aux
liens privilégiés s'ajoute une autre
condition gagnante
il faut y mettre du temps peut-être sous
profite de chaque moment pour créer des
occasions d'apprentissage tous les jours
16h10
ils vont écouter la télé on en aurait en
japonais s'apprêtent à un espagnol et
l'enfant point d'exploser à peu près 25%
du temps une langue pour pouvoir l
apprendre la maîtrise et ça fait pas
longtemps que par ça fait peut-être même
pas six mois
un enfant qui apprend plusieurs langues
dès la naissance va peut-être consolider
ses différentes grammaire un peu plus
tard qu'un enfant qui apprend seulement
non plus
et à chaque jour depuis un an et demi
les enfants vont à la garderie c'est ici
que leur vie francophone a commencé à
l'eau gimme gimme s'équiper amis ou
c'est nous les présenter dans son groupe
ronnie est comme un poisson dans l'eau
et est pour toi c'est toi les occuper
les coupes et aranda avec fais moi je
pense qu'ils comptent pas bien ce
concept qui est capable de trouver les
façons de s'exprimer quand tu trouves
pas
ronnie est prêt pour la maternelle à
l'on vend ni cas
mika sont français voit très bien les
peines de plus signé de réserve et
l'équitation s'ajoute une autre
dimension à l'apprentissage des langues
ici pour le français évidemment c'est
pas le même vocable vocabulaire qu'on va
utiliser qu'un cas la garderie ou avec
ses amis
qu'est ce qu'on fait reléguer triompher
des colonies est un enfant heureux
il a du plaisir à jouer avec les langues
la motivation c'est d'ailleurs un
facteur de réussite important pour
apprendre une langue
il faut qu'un enfant soit motivée elle
apprend donc il faut que ce soit des
contextes ludiques ou des contextes
nécessaires à la survie donc c'est les
deux extrêmes mien c'est donc avec le
poney sam loin des cours académiques
colonies et sa maman viennent parfaire
leur français en société c'est à partir
de votre philosophie n'est pas quelque
chose qu il n en plus intégré cette
dimension de passage
le rêve de titres ou prend forme
ces enfants pour grandir dans un monde
sans frontières
sachant que les enfants apprennent cinq
langues simultanément quelle est la vie
domestique
moi je suis un québécois c'est ce qu'
ils vont avoir cette pole dans la vie
ils vont être des plus calmes et lyon
1-1 et le petit dernier aquila dans tout
ça maintenant toujours c'est qu'elle l'a
rêvé ou l'arrondi la couleur la langue
couleurs